Walid Hijazi avocat est avec nous Amélie
démarrer journaliste qui a suivi de A à
Z se presser le bonsoir à vous deux
Walid je commence avec vous qu'est-ce
que la couronne de vais prouver pour en
arriver à un meurtre au deuxième degré
d'abord j'ai rappelé nous la différence
1er degré et 2e degré de qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait prouver pour 2e degré ok alors
c'est pas le 1er degré et 2e degré
Amherst à 13h le niveau de station morte
au premier degré ce qui a été fait à
l'avance on était pas dans cet univers
en connaissance de cause
la madame elle a témoigné elle avait dit
que
si on veut la voir barricader l'avoir à
rouler avec du ruban mets le dis j'ai
jamais pensé que ça allait là dessus et
ça n'a pas été cru par le jury elle
était trop de morts deuxième parce que
elle disait
on aurait pu s'attendre à une
condamnation pour homicide involontaire
oui j'ai fait ça mais je voulais que tu
aies
plusieurs fois pendant
qu'elle n'avait pas
un peu plus tôt dans la matinée
détester la Fiat qu'elle avait une
inversion pour elle et il faut le dire
le procureur mettre Jean-Sébastien
monsieur a été très efficace dans sa
plaidoirie et probablement que ça a joué
dans le verdict ils sont tous la
rapidité avec laquelle il a été rendu
donc le fait que ça a été rendu comme
dit Amélie de façon
en moins de 4h on est prêt à donner
notre verdict ça vous dit que bien avant
la fin du procès l'ai juré tu es
convaincu qu'avec attention de donner la
mort
de tout doute raisonnable de cette
attention la est manifestement délibérée
très longtemps alors que ça a duré
plusieurs semaines 26 témoins une
matière quand même assez chargée assez
lourd et des nations à droite qui ne
sont pas simple mais effectivement ils
ont passé tout ce temps là ça mais ils
ont passé plusieurs semaines ensemble à
regarder avec faut que se focaliser
uniquement sur ce dossier là en privé
mais là qu'elle arrive et elle te fait
au moment de commencer la délibération
ils ont dû confirmer certaines aspect ok
tout le monde est unanime Verdier Amélie
dans quelle mesure parce que les les
jours ils ne viennent pas de la planète
Mars dans quelle mesure
savait tellement ce quiz Québec
l'annonce de la mort de cette jeune
fille est la jeune martyrs de Granby
dans quelle mesure on n'a pas voulu
aussi ou de détails punir la belle-mère
qui a fait des gestes impardonnable et
que Steph presque d'avant jouer là mais
je voudrais ça a été sur la vitesse avec
laquelle on a réussi à sélectionner le
jury on sait que tu avais lieu à
Trois-Rivières justement parce que c'est
des événements qui avait eu lieu à
grimper et que la bosse arrêter de
trouver des personnes qui sont impartial
ici ça a été rendement la la sélection
du jury les gens qu'il n'avait pas de
bien je voudrais qu'on avait à faire
d'ailleurs à un groupe de jury très
consciencieux il posait des questions il
n'était pas Spider-Man et moi non plus
je voudrais
des injures et un jury qui était
rationnelle y a eu quelques larmes là
mais honnêtement je voudrais que il
était assez de glace la tout au long
écrivez attentivement
la peine
prison à vie pour un meurtre ça soit 1er
au 2e degré mais la libération
conditionnelle
pour un meurtre au deuxième degré je
crois que c'est 10 ans donc elle
pourrait sortir après 10 ans ou c'est il
faut attendre que le juge dire ah bah ça
va alors effectivement qu'on parle de
meurtre c'est la peine et les
criminels son minimum c'est
ce qui se décide c'est à la libération
conditionnelle alors pour un marteau 2e
degré c'est ça c'est 25 ans et c'est le
juge qui va décider il a demandé au jury
s'il y avait une recommandation le jure
il a pas voulu se prononcer ça
appartient au juste avec lui de décider
alors ça va c'est un minimum de 10 ans
elle va nécessairement devoir faire
ferme entre les murs d'un pénitencier
après ça qu'elle sera la peine comment
le juge vos mots du lait la peine ou la
peine la période de la libération
conditionnelle selon les particularités
de la part ça va jouer en 25 ans ça doit
être proportionnelle ça doit être
individualisé il y a plusieurs facteurs
à évaluer mais c'est le juge qui est le
mieux placé qui va prendre la décision
Amélie le père qu'est-ce qui arrive on
perd son procès va suivre il fait face à
des accusations qui sont moins grave
quand même que la belle-mère on part de
négligence criminelle cause en a marre
d'avoir omis de fournir les choses
nécessaires à la vie d'un enfant
d'abandon d'enfants et de séquestration
dans son procès va s'ouvrir en janvier
un appel
c'est possible
le délibéré ça c'est sacré alors nous
les avons quand on regarde les
directives alors que le juge a fait hier
matin les instructions qu'il donne en
droit est-ce que des erreurs dans la
façon d'expliquer c'est quoi un meurtre
au deuxième degré expliquer la
séquestration le fardeau de la
présomption d'innocence est-ce qu'il
s'est trompé à ce niveau-là où on va
regarder les clés du processus est-ce
que le juge au courant du procès de la
preuve qui n'arrête pas de la preuve
préjudiciable la preuve illégale mais
que le juge a permis c'est le genre de
choses qu'on va regarder
semblablement les avocats vont vérifier
si
vous avez découvert
dans la carrière de il y a des
événements qui nous Marc Marquez
journaliste avoir un juge qui a quand
même une certaine répartie avant les
échanges également entre les avocats
quand tu es parti à discuter également
avec la grand-mère de cette petite fille
à qui nous a longuement entretenu la les
journalistes qui était très généreuse ça
a été vraiment un processus
de façon pour moi effectivement
personne chant de la
Victoire il y a eu beaucoup de sobriété
dans la réaction des procureurs il a dit
alors
la famille de la victime on le résultat
qu'ils ont souhaité mais c'est pas un
moment de célébration non plus c'est un
procès qui sert à sa fin merci beaucoup
à vous deux bonne soirée au revoir